uh who's on your Mount Rushmore of
Atlanta Hip Hop all time
[__] I don't know
um [__] [__] right now who yours
let me see I'm gonna go Andre 3 000.
that's a good one
tip
cheesy
future
no I gotta take TI off Jeezy
future Gucci
okay and Andre three thousand hundred
three thousand good too I like that
lineup right now I like that that's a
good lineup what's your lineup man I
don't really got one give me give me
four
I can't just be like yeah you asked me
to I gave you my answer oh [__] I ain't
got one you ain't got you give me some
names that should be concerned who's
sitting in the waiting room waiting to
hear their name called to be on the
Mount Rushmore is that you know what I
mean
I don't know let me see it George
um I'm gonna say future
I'm gonna say Gucci we like that old
Gucci locked in on that [__]
that's the NR in hip-hop yeah except a
little while
[Music]
[__] nudity
that's a good great answer seven Great
enhancer oh
oh baby Drew
you know who I would put on there too oh
well who else should I put on there if I
could put them all on as one the Migos
the Amigo yeah I might take off
Gucci
for the Amigos as a whole yeah yeah
I like the whole Migos as a group all
three
as one person I just listen to me goes a
lot the old they owes you oh man it's so
good yeah yeah oh [__] too that was a
that was a funny yeah that was an ERA
Peewee too yeah PeeWee Longway yeah and
he don't get enough uh give him more
credit man he's supposed to get a lot
more credit he was hard Scooter's hard
too he'd be on that boot in the night
light huh be on that boot and not like
say what
to be on the boot in my life it back in
day [__]
we should be on boot in Nightline
we went over there please explain okay
oh okay so yeah at least be on the mind
so the Molly's be running around the
lobby forever
you just be running around on Molly
right lower man back in no day let me
see back in the book day the bank order
we probably use list two probably
goddamn future
bloody J
PeeWee Longway
amigo
foreign
[Music]
about it for real for real
airplanes some other [__] that was
from Atlanta but
um they probably was a poor side [__]
so we're gonna fall down we're gonna
keep it going oh yeah yeah